on twitter
somebody pointed me to a story uh a
bunch of people pointed me to a story
a few months ago where you went into a
restaurant in new york
and you can correct me famous is wrong
and ran into a bunch of folks
from a company in a crypto company who
are trying to scale up ethereum
and they had a technical deadline
related to a solidity to ovm compiler
so these are all ethereum technologies
so
you stepped in they recognized you
uh pulled you aside explained their
problem and you stepped in and helped
them
solve the problem uh thereby creating
legend status story so uh
can you uh tell me the story
the little more detail it seems kind of
incredible
this did this happen yeah yeah it's a
true story it's a true story i mean
they wrote a very flattering account of
it um
they so optimism is the
spin the company is called optimism
spin-off of plasma
they're trying to build l2 solutions on
ethereum so right now
uh every ethereum node has to run
every transaction on the ethereum
network
um and this kind of doesn't scale right
because if you have n computers
well you know if that becomes two n
computers you actually still get the
same amount of compute
right this is this is like like of one
scaling
um because they all have to run it okay
fine you get more
blockchain security but like the
blockchain's already so secure
can we trade some of that off for speed
uh so that's kind of what these l2
solutions are
they built this thing which kind of um
kind of sandbox
for ethereum contracts so they can run
it in this l2 world and it can't do
certain things in l world
in l1 can ask you for some definitions
what's l2
oh l2 is layer 2. so l1 is like the base
ethereum chain
and then layer 2 is like a computational
layer that runs
um elsewhere but still is kind of
secured by layer 1.
and i'm sure a lot of people know but
ethereum is a cryptocurrency
probably one of the most popular
cryptocurrencies second to bitcoin
and a lot of interesting technological
innovations there
maybe you can also slip in
whenever you talk about this any things
that are exciting to you in the
ethereum space and why ethereum well i
mean
bitcoin uh is not tar and complete
well ethereum is not technically a
terrain complete with a gas limit but
close enough well the gas limit what's
the gas limit
sources yeah i mean no computers
actually turn complete right
right you're gonna find that ram you
know guys
i can actually solve the whole gas limit
you just have so many brilliant
work i'm not even gonna that's not my
word that's ethereum's word
gasoline ethereum you have to spend gas
per instruction
so like different op codes use different
amounts of gas and you buy gas with
ether
to prevent people from basically ddosing
the network so
uh bitcoin is proof of work and then
what's ethereum it's also proof of work
uh they're working on some proof of
stake ethereum 2.0 stuff but right now
it's
it's proof of work it uses a different
hash function from bitcoin that's more
asic resistance because you need ram
so we're all talking about ethereum 1.0
so what uh
what were they trying to do to scale
this whole process so they were like
well
if we could run contracts elsewhere um
and then only save the results of that
computation
uh you know well we don't actually have
to do the computer on the chain we can
do the compute off chain and just post
what the results are
now the problem with that is well
somebody could lie about what the
results are
so you need a resolution mechanism and
the resolution mechanism can be really
expensive
uh because you know you just have to
make sure that like
the person who is saying look i swear
that this is the real computation
i'm staking ten thousand dollars on that
fact and
if you prove it wrong yeah it might cost
you three thousand dollars in gas fees
to prove wrong
but you'll get the ten thousand dollar
bounty so you can secure
using those kind of systems um
so it's effectively a sandbox which runs
contracts
uh and like just like any kind of normal
sandbox you have to like replace
syscalls with um you know calls into the
hypervisor
uh sandbox this calls hypervisor what do
these things mean
uh as long as it's interesting to talk
about yeah i mean you can take like the
chrome sandboxes maybe the one to think
about right so the chrome process that's
doing the rendering
uh can't for example read a file from
the file system yeah
it has if it tries to make an open
syscall in linux the open system
you can't make it open says call no no
no uh you have to request
from the kind of uh hypervisor process
or
like i don't know what's called in
chrome but um
the canoe hey could you open this file
for me and then it does all these checks
and then it passes the file handle back
in if it's approved
um so that's yeah uh so what's the in
the context of
ethereum what are the boundaries of the
sandbox that we're talking about
well like one of the calls that you
actually reading and uh
writing any state to the ethereum
contract
to the ethereum blockchain um
writing state is one of those calls that
you're going to have to
sandbox in layer two because
if you let layer two just arbitrarily
write to the ethereum blockchain
um so layer two is like set is really
sitting on top of
layer one so you're gonna have a lot of
different kinds of ideas that you can
play with
yeah and they're all they're not
fundamentally changing
the source code level of ethereum
well you have to replace a bunch of
calls
with calls into the hypervisor so
instead of doing the syscall directly
you you replace it with a call to the
hypervisor
so originally they were doing this by
first running the so solidity is the
language that most ethereum contracts
are written in
it compiles to a bytecode and then they
wrote this thing they called the
transpiler
and the transpiler took the bytecode and
it transpiled it into
ovm safe bytecode basically bytecode
that didn't make any of those restricted
sys calls and added the calls to the
hypervisor
this transpiler was a 3000 line mess
and it's hard to do it's hard to do if
you're trying to do it like that because
you have to kind of like deconstruct the
byte code
change things about it and then
reconstruct it
and i mean as soon as i hear this i'm
like why don't you just change the
compiler
right why not the first place you build
the bytecode just do it in the compiler
uh so yeah you know i asked them how
much they wanted it
uh of course measured in dollars and i'm
like well okay
um and yeah and you wrote the compiler
i modified i wrote a 300 line diff to
the compiler uh it's open source you can
look at it
yeah it's yeah i looked at the code last
night it's
cute yeah exactly cute kid is a good
word for it
uh and it's uh c plus plus
see so when asked
how you were able to do it you said
you just got to think and then do it
right
so can you break that apart a little bit
what's what's your process of uh
one thinking and two doing it right
you know they they the people i was
working for were amused that i said that
it doesn't really mean anything
okay i mean is there some
deep profound insights to draw from like
how you problem solve from because this
is always what i say i'm like do you
want to be a good programmer do it for
20 years
yeah there's no shortcuts yeah
you